الى ايران الان حيث يواصل مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفيال جروسي زيارته
لهذا البلد بهدف حل القضايا العالقه بين
الجانبين بشان ملف ايران النووي وقد وصف
مدير الوكاله خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في طهران
اجواء محادثات هناك بالشفافه مشيرا الى ان
الهدف هو اجراء محادثات جاده وعميقه بخصوص
الملف النووي
يجب ان يكون لدينا محادثات جاده وعميقه مع
ايران فهي هدف زيارتي ما زال العمل جاريا
وستستمر اللقاءات مع رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايراني وبقيه المسؤولين وفي
النهايه سنكون قادرين على الحكم بشان
مستوى الرضا من هذه الزياره لكن دعوني
اؤكد ان الاجواء هي اجواء عمل وشفافيه
وتعاون وهذا الامر اهم نقطه بالنسبه لي
ومحادثاتنا ستستمر
وخرج روسيا من الوكاله تستنكر اي هجوم او
تهديد على المنشات النوويه في العالم
واضاف ان اي هجوم عسكري على المنشات
النوويه عمل غير قانونيه
هذا الموقف واضح جدا واعلن ليس فقط من
جانب الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بل من
جانب المجتمع الدولي ايضا عبر عدد كبير من
القرارات التي صدرت عن الوكاله الدوليه
التي استنكرت بوضوح اي هجوم او تهديد على
المنشات النوويه اعتقد ان اي هجوم عسكري
على منشاه نوويه عمل غير قانوني ويتعارض
مع الاطر التي نلتزم بها جميعا